nine years after its initial
announcement Dead Island 2 is real and
it's finally almost time for fans to get
their hands on it here is everything you
need to know about Dead Island 2.
Dead Island 2 takes place in Los Angeles
California AKA not on an island like the
title suggests this version of La
cleverly nicknamed helle by The Game's
developers is brimming with Undead
creatures of all shapes and sizes at the
start of the game you're making an
attempt to escape the City by plane
unfortunately things don't go as planned
and you end up right back in The
Condemned Streets of LA fighting your
way through hordes of zombies looking
for fellow survivors there are six
playable characters AKA Slayers for you
to choose from each with their own
personality voice lines and starting
stats Jacob is a former London
stockbroker turned Hollywood stuntman
his innate skills allow for a minor
damage boost while attacking in quick
succession as well as a critical damage
boost while his stamina is low Clara is
also into stunts but specifically of the
motorcycle variety her innate skills
include a moderate toughness boost while
her health is critical and a minor
damage boost when close to multiple
zombies Ryan is an exotic dancer dressed
as a fireman on a mission to rescue his
little brother who was left behind in
Fresno California before the outbreak
Ryan has only one innate skill that
gives him a moderate Force boost when
trying to block or Dodge to avoid an
attack Bruno is a hustler that pulled
off Heist before the zombocalypse began
his innate skills give him a moderate
damage boost when attacking zombies from
behind and a boost to his agility and
heavy attack charges when he avoids
attacks with a block or Dodge Danny is a
brawler from Ireland that wrecked roller
derby teams before the outbreak her
innate skills include bloodlust a
generation of Health when slaying
multiple zombies in quick succession and
Thunderstruck a forceful explosion of
dany's heavy attacks Amy is described as
a quick-witted paralympian her Nate
skills give her stamina regeneration
when hitting a zombie with a weapon
throw and a minor damage boost when Amy
is attacking isolated zombies
unfortunately you can't swap characters
on the same save file but these
differences could be a great incentive
to replay the game five more times or
mix in other characters with your Co-op
group
Dead Island 2 is a first person
semi-open World action RPG throughout
the game you'll explore iconic Los
Angeles locations such as Venice Beach
and Beverly Hills but all these areas
are stitched together by loading screens
instead of being one big seamless World
in our preview for the game Mark Delaney
said quote sometimes the way these areas
would snake around surrounded by
unclimbable walls felt very restrictive
closer to a game as tightly set as
Bioshock rather than the original Dead
Island's large hubs while this is a much
more linear game than its predecessors
there are many optional nooks in each
area I encountered many locked rooms
safes and loot caches that would each
require further investigating or even
backtracking some of which wasn't
possible in my limited demo but
exploration is nothing if you have no
way of surviving against the undead in
Dead Island 2 weapons come in different
varieties headhunting weapons provide
blunt force naming weapons are slow and
remove Limbs and frenzy weapons allow
for fast slashing and dashing but Dead
Island 2 doesn't just limit you to only
melee combat there are a variety of guns
and opportunities for environmental
kills as well from sparking a gas leak
with a homemade electrified weapon to
kicking them into a pool full of
military-grade poisonous sludge that
causes their skin to melt off like ice
cream in the sun Mark described his
experience in our preview and said quote
combining my modded weapons throwables
like bait and pipe bombs and things
lying around such as gas canisters and
would be electrical hazards helps to
keep the combat interesting and it's all
made better by being tougher than I
expected instead of a traditional skill
tree Dead Island 2 features skill cards
not to be confused with the card system
and back for blood these collectible
items can be scavenged off the body of
zombies found in hidden locations all
over LA or gained from Simply leveling
up but they aren't just to look at skill
cards can be equipped to Grant you
special abilities and gain the upper
hand in combat there is a Dodge and a
block card that each if timed well can
stun enemies and help you regain your
stamina a war cry card can weaken nearby
enemies and boost the toughness of you
and your squad there's no mention of how
many skill cards are in the game but the
good news is a majority of them can be
used by all six of the game's playable
characters what makes this system even
more exciting is that the abilities of
the cards in your deck can be combined
for some pretty cool results
just like in the first game in the
series Dead Island 2 will feature
drop-in Dropout Co-op the game will let
you and two of your friends team up to
take down zombies together unfortunately
for the gamers that love to hang out on
the couch with their friends Dead Island
2 will not support Split Screen Co-op
Dead Island 2 is being developed by
dambuster Studios and published by Deep
Silver the game was announced nine years
ago disappeared for long periods of time
and changed developers more than once in
the beginning di2 started development
with jaeger as the original Dead Island
1 Studio teclan had moved on to begin
working on Dying Light the Polish Studio
later revealed it was not making Dead
Island 2 due to what one Tech land
developer described as quote a lot of
moments where we would disagree on
Creative Vision of the project would
publisher deep silver in 2016 it was
announced that Sumo digital was taking
over development but after the game went
dark for a couple years many believe the
project was quietly canceled fast
forward to 2019 and THQ Nordic confirmed
again that Dead Island 2 was in
production from its third studio in the
lead spot jambuster Studios co-creators
of Homefront Revolution THQ Nordic
sibling company Koch media today known
as PlayOn suggested that the seems long
development cycle was a good thing
actually the company CEO said quote it's
a testimony of our dedication to getting
it right
[Music]
Dead Island 2 will be available for PS4
PS5 Xbox One series X and S and PC via
the epic game store on April 21st 2023
there will be three versions of the game
for fans to choose from standard Deluxe
and Gold Edition the standard edition
will cost 60 USD on PC and 70 usd on
Console it comes with the base game and
the memories of Benoit pack as a
pre-order bonus the deluxe edition will
cost you 65 USD on PC 75 USD on Console
this version comes with the same stuff
as the standard in addition to the gold
weapons pack and Character Pack 1 and 2.
the Gold Edition will run you 80 USD on
PC and 90 on Console it comes with
everything from the standard in Deluxe
as well as the pulp weapons pack and
expansion pass and there you have it
everything you need to know about Dead
Island 2. for more on the game including
guides and our review keep it locked to
GameSpot
[Music]